you can get away with corruption if
you're a democrat
hunter biden expected to meet with
potential art buyers later this year
despite not having any formal
qualifications or training
the paintings could fetch up to about
half a million bucks
and the white house thinks this is all
perfectly fine
that he is attending uh gallery events
that have been prior
prior plans and that is different than
meeting with prospective buyers
the selling of his art will all happen
through galer the gallerists
and the names and individuals will be
kept confidential we will not be aware
neither will he be aware
he will not know we will not know who
purchases his art
but the watchdogs are blasting the art
scheme including
obama's former ethics chief
can you find anyone other than a
president's son who showed up on the
scene and started selling for the cost
of
a house and a half it sure looks like
profiting off the presidency
i have a feeling if he did it under her
pen name he wouldn't get much for it
jesse i love i well i hate yoga but i
love
this kind of verbal yoga i'm totally
into this it's
hunter bind's going to meet with
potential buyers but he's not going to
know who the real
buyers are and there's no scenario in
which
buyers can provide influence yeah okay
all right you can tell
jen saki had to take a shower after that
briefing i know
jen saki and i can see her body language
and her facial expressions
everyone knows she's lying she doesn't
want to have to say this but she has to
say it because that's her job
art is subjective so you can inflate the
cost
based on nothing there's no market value
for art so it's total bs and the way
that it buys influence is this
donors are not giving to buy there's a
cat right 2500 a donation
800 whatever it is per family right or
you could give to a super pac but again
that's still declosed and you have to
use it on the campaign
this is a direct donation to the biden
family
and hunter biden has a history of
using the money that he's gained through
working off his father's
name to pay for the finances and the
expenses of the biden family
for aunts for uncles for joe himself for
kids for
all that stuff so that's the game and
when you're making a donation
you're making a heavy heavy donation to
the biden family
that's much more influential than just a
random donation to the campaign
so to say that it's anonymous at first
remember just anonymous owner and now
hunter's meeting with this
so-called anonymous donor you don't
think he's ever gonna find out who paid
a million
a million dollars to the biden family
it's not to the biden campaign it's to
the biden family that pays for
homes and utility bills and cars
all of that stuff that is a major that
is undue
influence and it can't be regulated and
that should be illegal
in a campaign finance format katie if
his art stood on his own
he wouldn't have to meet the buyers to
grease the wheels
okay what's preventing someone who buys
his art from texting hunter biden and be
like
i bought the art from you there's no
there's nothing preventing him from
finding out
who these potential buyers and then you
return the favor
eventually and you find out who it is i
this is amazing to me
people are he's he's making art by
blowing
paint through a glass straw in his pool
house which is
really gross like who's paying five
hundred thousand dollars
to buy hunter biden's spit on
canvas actually like that's what's
happening right that is
actually spit on with paint on canvas
it's just amazing and
to me joe biden not putting his foot
down on this i think is very telling
about
why they're allowing it to continue
because
hunter biden made all that money
charisma he still has a 10
stake in a chinese company he has enough
money and joe biden isn't telling him
like
you can do your little hobby with your
spit and your spittle
in the pool house you can't sell it
until i leave the white house
or wait four years he gets book deals
for what 20 million dollars
for a half a million
no i was agreeing because when you said
why hasn't uh
why hasn't somebody asked the president
to put his foot down because
you have you're wondering how much does
the white house spend on this particular
issue when you have
rampant crime you've got the pandemic
you would think that there would be some
i hate to use the phrase reading the
room because clearly hunter can't read
the room but somebody has to say look
you guys
this is really a destructive waste of
time
we have all this other stuff going on
and you're answering questions and we're
creating these
these bizarre strategies this idea that
somehow a lack of transparency
is transparency if if anybody had pulled
this stuff off
it would never have happened by the way
if this were a black individual
an average black you already would have
been imprisoned for the gun violations
and for the drugs so this is the
ultimate white privilege and it's in
your face
the other thing to to to the point about
the art this is children's art
it shows you how stunted this guy is is
that this is an arts and crafts project
it's second grade like it's one step
away
from finger painting i don't know who
said this might have been scott adams
donald trump jr should just start
selling finger paints
tomorrow just for on a lark and see how
much money he can get
because uh this it's just amazing to me
maybe we maybe his dad is putting this
in context
look he's not impregnating strippers
right so this is a step up and he's not
it's not going up his nose it's going
out his mouth so
maybe this is sorry you got to stop you
got somebody's got to put their foot
down where's dr jill
he's got enough money to rent a very
fancy house i think it's in venice beach
california
jessica and also drive around in a
porsche panamera
which he was cruising around in when he
did the interview last year on the
campaign trail
yeah so why didn't it have some money
and we've done an investigation into
when joe biden
interviewed intervened with barisma and
it actually ended up hurting the company
more than helping it but i want to talk
about
the fact that a i do not think he should
be meeting donors there had to be some
way to execute this where it would be
completely private and maybe it gets
found out four
eight years from now the guy also has to
be able
to work and you can insult his art
though jesse i think he's going to buy a
few pieces
if he saves that wait wait wait a second
i thought he was this international
businessman with all of these skills
with regards to natural gas
you can't do something that doesn't
conflict with the white house
well this barely conflicts the white
house
i really want to say this part we cannot
have this conversation and completely
ignore
the fact that trump children ivanka and
jared
according to the citizens for ethics
investigation made hundreds of millions
of dollars
while they were serving in government
posts ivanka got done no jesse don't put
your hands up
she got dozens of trademarks including
three preliminary trademarks we gotta go
the day she ate with xi jinping she's
at mar-a-lago she's watching this for
two decades he just
started blowing up are you kidding me if
chelsea clinton was like
oh i'm selling my fancy shoes we gotta
go i had dinner with you
i want to clear this up those trademarks
were they filed for those well before he
was uh trump
the white house is using taxpayer
resources to manage hunter biden's
a career which is absurd you guys want
me to say that hunter's a bad boy and
you won't even admit the fact
that what they did is preposterous uh
joe biden's president
and uh i love how you referred to the
potential art buyers jessica
as donors so you just ate jesse's salad
yes you did you used the word donors and
i just love it